[Music]
but mistakes make you strong
hey guys now this might make some of you
feel very uncomfortable
but let's talk about this like men let's
talk about
pornography more specifically why you
should stop
watching porn i know in a lot of
cultures today people say everybody does
it it's fine
you can watch porn i remember when i was
young an older guy wanted to give me
porn and he said everybody does it go
ahead it's fine everybody does it it's
normal
and that's the lie he told himself and
the lie most people tell themselves
today is not true and even if a lot of
people watch
porn just because something is common
that does not mean that it's good or
healthy for you
in fact it's actually very toxic to our
society
now there are three very big reasons why
you should stop watching
pornography but before we get into it
let me give you some
statistics so that you will know more
about the truth
regarding pornography 11 years old is
the average age
a child is first exposed to porn the
younger boys get to porn
the less capacity they have for empathy
for girls and women
and the more likely they are to become
sexual offenders
according to the chicago tribune and
according to fightthenewdrug.org
recorded child sexual exploitation aka
child porn
is one of the fastest growing online
businesses
and 624 000 child porn traders
have been discovered online in the us
now you need to know that
pornography and sexual trafficking
goes hand in hand it makes me want to
throw up
sick they also say that 64 of young
people
ages 13 to 24 actively seek out
pornography
weekly or more often
and here's the thing is not just men
psychology today says it's surprising
that 2019 google analytics data
showed that the audience for pornhub one
of the world's most popular porn sites
is 32 female now here's the scary part
about people who watch porn according to
husbandhelphaven.com
most people who look at porn are
addicted but only 1 in
200 believe that they are all right now
that you know a little bit more about
this
let me give you three big reasons why
you should stop watching
porn
you support sex trafficking
yes sex trafficking
if you watch porn you support and cause
these people to stay in business
and to create content for you not all
porn is connected with it but most of it
is
according to fight the new drug it's
estimated that 4.8
million people are trapped or forced
into sexual exploitation
globally in one survey 63 percent of
underage
sex trafficking victims said that they
have been advertised or sold
online according to anti-trafficking
non-profit
rescue freedom in nine countries 49
of sexually exploited women said that
pornography was made of them
while they were being sold for sex this
is sick imagine if this happens to your
wife
your sister or to your daughter
it will make you a worse man overall
because it changes the way that you
think it makes you a slave to it
you get addicted to it just like drugs
according to marietta daily journal and
the seattle times
studies show that addiction to porn is
as powerful as the chemical dependency
on cocaine it's got a similar effect on
your brain
be honest with yourself do you watch
porn
how many times do you watch pornography
can you go without
it for a month a week a day
if not then you are addicted to porn
and this is how it changes you according
to bbc.com studies found
that watching porn could shrink a part
of the brain
linked to pleasure meaning people might
need more graphic material
to get aroused so you might think you're
just entertaining yourself
nobody sees you you're not hurting
anybody
but you're hurting your brain because
you see your brain is busy building
pathways between
pornography and your feelings so the
type of porn that you watch over time
change becomes more aggressive
you need it to be more graphic and then
it influences
your relationships your marriage
because normal amazing great
sex is not good enough anymore for you
according to inforum viewing pornography
lead to poorer
relationships and married men who watch
porn are twice as
likely to get divorced why
because you start to compare your wife
to the woman
you watch in porn and then you start to
look at women
not as human beings but as objects
so it skews and it distorts the way you
think of healthy sex and according to
fight the new drug
porn takes all the intimacy out of
sexuality
porn promotes sex as an exploitive and
selfish
act that's all about performance and not
about
connection sex in marriage is not bad
sex in marriage making love is good
and it's healthy but not when you are
objectifying
people for selfish pleasure
that's not healthy husband help haven
says people who look at porn
are 22 percent more likely to commit a
sexual
crime and in 56 of divorces
at least one spouse has an obsessive
interest
in porn that's crazy it just shows us
what big a
problem pornography really is
[Music]
porn is just a fantasy it's not real
life
it's just pixels on the screen most
people who watch porn they don't even
care about the people
who are in it they don't know what's
going on behind the scenes of those
people
what are they struggling with they are
actors
let me tell you a little bit about them
according to a husband help haven almost
70 percent of actors and actresses in
the adult film industry
have herpes and 50 of them use
ecstasy 79 use marijuana and 44
cocaine why do you think they are using
all of these things
when they're doing porn you think it's
easy for them to do it
they wouldn't be able to do it without
those things without using
cocaine and marijuana all of these
things they're just
oh they just need the strength to go
through this
and 88 of the adult movies show scenes
with physical aggression or
dominance and remember what i said at
the beginning of this video
4.8 million people are forced into
sexual exploitation
and in nine countries 49 of them were
used to make
porn so you think you're just watching
porn but you don't even know
if there's a guy behind a camera that's
standing there with a gun
let that just sink in a little bit
and i haven't even scratched the surface
including child pornography it's sick
and if you believe in god it's one of
the biggest
reasons why you should stop watching
porn
and i'll make a video about that about
how to overcome porn how to stop
watching it on my other channel called
dlm christian lifestyle so don't miss
that video
it's time to fight this don't be a slave
to it
master your mind to master your body
guys don't let this control you
you need to control it if you haven't
subscribed yet to my channel then please
do
so you won't miss any of the next videos
and i'll see you in the next one
cheers guys